the pride of Pittsburgh PA a local boy
made good he has directed some of the
best films of the last two decades
certainly a lot of them starring Denzel
Washington the fourth time that they
have teamed up the equalizer two in
theaters on Friday he is Antoine Fuqua
good to see you sir good to see you
so Pittsburgh PA yeah okay
I mean Steelers right absolutely you did
not stutter not even a little bit let's
get right into it now
your cousin mm is frenchie fuqua that's
right who had all those great shoes
right and the goldfish goldfish and
shoes yeah it's like a childhood memory
of your selfishness yes absolutely with
the capes and hats you know that was a
bet to hit him Franco Harris and all
those guys who could get the most
attention by dressing up and he won
because he had to go fishing issues you
know look at that photo we're showing
right now look at those look at the
collars yeah look at the hats I mean you
know nowadays the broadened them they
got nothing on these cats so do you
remember the Immaculate reception
oh are you okay remember okay have you
ever had a conversation with York I have
yeah okay where where did the football
hit according to you know what he told
me what do you tell you I'll never tell
you will never tell what he told you or
he told you he told me I'll never tell
see now if he says I'll never tell isn't
that isn't that a tell to use I guess a
poke really so you have specifically
asked your cousin about web salute where
did that ball hit off solutely many
times I've said did it hit the ground
hit the shoulder with the ball he says
I'll never tell I'll never I'll never
tell
yep cuz you can't tell him there it is
you know you can't change the whole
legacy ya know the game there it goes
you know so I'm connected forever it did
change the legacy so that was a hard hit
he talked he did well I mean it took it
the hit hit you know I mean I mean Tatum
is his real bad guys they
you know hitter you could get so so back
in in the day you know did you go to
these games with the finger I didn't
really have to go to the game talk to
young you know I watch from TV a lot I'm
trying to get a chance to go but uh I
watched ok I was there are you still a
Steeler fan right now absolutely yeah
you kidding me man they would come find
me and beat the crap out of me if you
did not this purse still Affairs travel
group for the Steelers anymore so I love
them outside of your cousin who's your
favorite Steeler right now Yeah right
well of all the wall tiles I'm a god man
then suam was an amazing athlete just
incredible you know I think Terry
Bradshaw doesn't get as much credit that
he deserves back then he was hated when
he first came to Pittsburgh you know
they didn't like him at all he came
through and flying coast
Mean Joe green Jack you know Jack
Lambert you know I see Mean Joe green
almost every August Hall of Fame oh
there's no comes this great well it
looks like he can give you a few snaps
you're probably still not different
people right now I mean it's still
curtain it's absolutely Marshall Faulk
could tell me the story all the time
that when Mean Joe green was coaching
for the Arizona Cardinals one did one
particular game the Cardinals were just
all over the RAM screaming and yelling
and given Marshall all sorts of grief
right and he just ripped one off scored
a touchdown look and he goes right back
to the sidelines it starts barking at
all the Cardinals players and you
realized he he saw Mean Joe green in
midst of all the people he's walking at
he goes back he goes not you that was
tough for real I know all those guys
were what do you think about what's
going on with love me on bail right now
Antoine uh you know I hope the Steelers
can find a way to you know make him
whole you know I mean he wants to get
paid as a receiver and running back but
uh he's worth it I think distillers
need them the franchise needs them I
think they can make him happy so that
they can get on and win a Super Bowl
well I mean they don't strike me the
Steelers is the team that's gonna break
you know precedence right and stardom
and start paying some running back like
a slot receiver slash pain
two positions in one guy they don't
strike me as that team it's gonna do
something no I think de still deserve
they stick to the tradition they stick
to their word mm-hmm
you either roll with it or you don't
they're gonna win either way I'll find a
way
mm-hmm but I think in this case the
world has changed a little bit
guys like living on Belgians don't come
around every day they don't so you know
they may have to bend the rule a little
bit
Brian I don't think it hurt anything I
love tomlin by the way I think I'm
hungry I don't understand why Steeler
fans sometimes they just you know
because obviously they've only won once
under Mike Talman right I mean won a
championship obviously win every year
under Eric Tomlin right and I just see
you know we'd love wants to get paid the
way he wants get paid Antonio Brown
business booms but sometimes it comes at
a little bit of a price awfully old Big
Ben is got his own set of issues and
Thomas I always say that there's an
iceberg and we see the tip and the rest
of it is what Tomlin handles in
Pittsburgh he's an unmovable object
Tomlin and he solved as a rod Pittsburgh
fans are tough right you know they're
some of the toughest fans in around
there's a tradition of winning if you
don't want it super bold and you didn't
win and Tommen gets some time a bad rap
about that
but um I think that the Who am I to say
but I think the higher power your
Antoine Fuqua directed a decorated
director exactly in Hollywood yes sir
I'll go back to Pittsburgh yeah I'm just
antwuan my family treats me the same as
always and everybody else as they should
right but uh I think that the the the
powers the the company the Rooney's the
you know they're great people I mean I
got to meet him once when I did a movie
with Kate I did shoot her she was in my
thumb and I got to meet Inara yeah
that's right okay and they're the
kindest people ever man they really are
sweet people I just think the world has
changed a bit and Pittsburgh a place of
tradition and we may have to bend a
little bit to to to bring us back to
where we want to be
and levy I might be the started that I
don't think that's gonna happen that's
in my fantasy I don't want to see them
go mmm
and I think that they're so young these
guys man you gotta you got to give them
a little bit of what they want what if
you're casting for a film Antoine Fuqua
and the best person for the role is a
New England Patriot would you would you
put that person in your film Tom Brady
let's just say Brady there's somehow
someway Brady is the best person for the
film 100% Tom Brady you put him in your
favorites
Bill Belichick you put him in your film
absolutely good they're great at what
they do great and you know I'm from
Pittsburgh man we want greatness okay
now now do I want to win another Super
Bowl absolutely not hold on a minute
James Harrison do you put no bridge too
far that now come on man you don't go to
the Patriots you don't go to the page
you go it can with the Baltimore and I
would have been like all right I
understand man you know you want to get
that last hurrah
but not the New England Patriots funny
went to the Bengals and everybody
shrugged it off no big deal but Patriots
man come on I just hurt my feelings are
so hurt I can't even believe I thought
it was a job so he needs to go find
another movie if he did okay and I don't
want that guy man I just wish she would
stayed at home Antoine Fuqua the
director of the equalizer two in
theaters knew you tomorrow want to take
a 60-second break come back and talk
about your career and working with
denzel you got us back in sixty seconds
here in the Rich Eisen show what is it
like working with Denzel Washington as
much as you have it's incredible you
know it's it's like a coach working with
a great athlete like you know he's gonna
come out and give it all he's got you
don't have to worry about whether he's
gonna show up and deliver I you just
have to have your game plan tight and
help guide the ship obviously but he's
uh it's like working with a great
athlete man do you know what you're
gonna get so great athletes however can
take some coaching as well oh yeah so
what is that relationship like with
and him his trust it's full trust you
know we trust each other he knows I'm
gonna do my job and be prepared and I
know where we're going and I trust he's
going to his job obviously but it all
comes down to trust and then if there's
something gone sideways or left or right
you know I I just guided my way and
denzel's gonna do his thing and so
obviously through four films now
together you've gained that trust but
what about training Day 2001 well it's a
quick store of training day so sure I
shot the first scene in training day
with him Ethan at the cafe I'm nervous
that's the first scene in the movie and
I'm working with Denzel Washington and I
get the scene done and I go you know mr.
Washington you want to come over look at
the monitor and see you know what I did
there he goes man you directed this
thing man
call me when you need me and walked away
and never ever came back and never ever
what looked at the monitor whenever I'm
making a movie with Denzel you know he
doesn't come look over my shoulder he
doesn't question it or anything he just
walks away so now the pressures on me
I'm standing there thinking if a man
like Denzel is trusting me to get it
right and he's not questioning it get it
right and so that sort of belief in me
helped a lot how old were you when you
did training day uh I was 30 when I shot
the movie I was 32 Wow yeah we got the
Academy Award oh yeah I just turned 33
yeah it's amazing it was a great way to
come out of the game it was amazing man
it was amazing because yeah I sit there
with Denzel and Ethan and I had my
monitors I walked away from the monitors
and was sit on an Apple box and just
watched them and talked to them it was
like being at the theater every day and
I never looked through the lens
except for setting up the shot and I set
up the shot and then I just sit there in
front of them in the back of the car
couldn't cut the car in half yeah I had
three or four different pieces of the
car and I was sitting on an Apple box
and I would forget to yell cut sometimes
I would just sit there and Denzel would
turn around start smile goes you're
gonna yell cut him anything would just
go at it I mean really a lot of that
stuff wasn't on a page so what was
ad-lib do you got
what do you have for me on that front
kind of fit on it well I mean it's not
you know the word yeah right yeah that
was Denzel I was sitting in and we're
sitting in the car and he just started
laughs and he says my Blanc and Ethan
just busted our laughing and I was like
dad keep that just keep doing it and he
kept doing it the whole movie how about
howling howling like a wolf yeah no he
did that he did that yeah that came to
him just like I'm just gonna help King
Kong ain't got nothing on me it just
came out of him we were what's not on
the page no no we were there that night
he was he gets so into the zone he's in
the moment mm-hmm and he did it and if
you look at that shot cuz I shot in a
morphic it's a buzz it's a little out of
focus and he did it and it was so
powerful he walked over to me he goes I
don't know where I came from he said I
hope you got it cuz that was it I didn't
have to get it twice and I told my
editor comrade buff I said man it's got
a buzz in it man I can't use that shot
he said nobody will ever mention it and
I said nah somebody's gonna notice he
said never it's so powerful no one ever
mentioned it well it's buzzed
well I'm director Antoine Fuqua here I
mean that's part of what you've got it
cuz obviously you gotta be a control
freak yeah doing what you do right yeah
okay doesn't work at home but any person
no no right but you got to be a
perfectionist and sometimes you gotta
give a little yeah to get a lot or to
accept what you know can't be repeated
even with an all-time great a goat like
Denzel Wright was right because this is
a moment if someone's like when the
moment happens you can't even comment on
a moment because then you've ruined the
moment
yeah you know what I mean shows almost
like you always have to be alert and
prepared when something happens to make
sure everything's in the right place to
to get it and as part of directing is
switch to someone like Denzel never to
tie his hands put the cameras in places
where you know you can capture those
moments that are real in equalizer
there's a moment you'll see when he's
with this kid Ashton who plays miles and
it's a powerful moment again it wasn't
on the page the scene is written on a
page
but it starts to happen and part of my
job is to not miss it
you know to catch it and then know how
to use it
do you still forget to yell cut with him
yeah yeah I do because I just you know
because it's open it's also technical
until that it's all technical right it's
all cranes and cameras and lights and
all this stuff right and then it's the
human quality in the relationships and
when that starts happening there's times
where it's just it's just beautiful and
that's the reason you make movies
Antoine Fuqua here on the Rich Eisen
show you've worked with Prince correct
yes what was that like that was strange
it was amazing but strange man what was
strange about it strange Prince calling
me at 2:00 in the morning he flew me
down there to do the most beautiful girl
in the world was minus 20 degrees I get
a call two in the morning half asleep he
goes what you doing I said was if he
says it's me I said who's me is that the
boss I said who's boss he says me it's
Prince I didn't know his voice was so
deep the first time you'd spoken him
yeah yeah cuz the record label said he
wanted me to do it
I mean his manager right said he wanted
me to come do the video and all that so
I flew down and to do it but I didn't
speak to him he liked the treatment I
wrote and all that but I didn't speak to
him so deep how deep like Barry White
did principal
corinthos voice is deep that was an act
he had a deep voice and he could play
basketball that yeah we knew right yeah
we've heard about his legendary pickup
games what's right he could ball man
but he had a deep voice game glasses
yeah and I saw him coming up so I he
called me two in the morning said I'm
ready to shoot I said we mean I gotta
get the crew you mean like now yeah like
now sleeping it's minus 20 degrees yeah
he goes come on we can get it together I
said let me call everybody I got
everybody together went to Paisley Park
people everywhere beautiful women that's
lounging around hanging out Paisley Park
it was like it's like a dream man and
I'm standing I'm waiting to see I'm sick
so where's Prince and it's these long
steps and I see this figure like Betty
Davis man coming down with this red
see-through Paisley outfit right no
underwear by the way
back so prince was the Prince Jules oh
my god wake up you see the video that's
what he has on he comes down the steps
and the hair and the face and he comes
down steps and it took everything in me
not to like just bust out laughing it's
like I'm ready and I'm looking at it I'm
going man we may have to cut we have the
covers of big stuff you know cuz he was
like nah I'm not changing and if all the
times that your camera couldn't have
been out of focus
the DPS had turned a light down okay
yeah and so was he like a one-take
artist I mean well he was amazing that I
pick out up on stage and he just did his
thing when an entertainer
I mean his halftime show in in the rain
we were talking about it earlier tonight
earlier on the show in the rain at the
Super Bowl yeah and and he was the only
halftime he's performer I wanna call him
an act right only halftime performer who
did not take questions in a QA prior to
the Super Bowl in a press setting he
said I'm gonna just perform two or three
songs and it was unbelievable tore the
house down he did well here's the thing
people like Denzel mm-hmm Denzel wasn't
like doing press and I said he likes to
do the work he just did a four-hour play
in New York Iceman Cometh people like
Prince they love the work you turn on
your camera as you turn on their mics
and they're the magic it just happens
you know it's something that's um it's a
gift they have and they're in the moment
it's like again you can't train Tom
Brady to be Tom Brady or Le'Veon Bell be
levy on bail Antonio Brown or Lynn Swann
any knees cut Michael Jordan it's
something in them that they have this
special and I think that's the best of
beauty of prints I mean I saw that when
I turned my cameras on because he was
the little guy you know he's a little
short guy right this whole thing no
Michael
going on man he got up one I stayed he
was a giant and I just my camera start
moving around him and I was just
fascinated with him so I've been blessed
to work with those you sure have and I
can't wait to see the equaliser 2 in
theaters tomorrow just the latest but
you and Denzel back at it again just as
just as good as ever thank you it's
great to see his greatness let's come
back come back uh when your Lakers start
playing with LeBron or Z or Celtics
because you've been in Boston so long
shouldn't you know I'm conflicted but
those those Boston boys are pretty tough
they are real they are very real I love
those kids man Tatum is no joke and no
joke and Nissen years ago I would never
say Boston I was about to say never
because you know magic right ya notice
you have to say about that but Boston
yeah about you saying that I don't know
I'll find out when I leave the show he's
just down the street here in El Segundo
be careful okay but LeBron is a monster
and so you know I wanted Kawhi to come
too just to be out there I went to Kauai
okay you know my prediction yeah whoo I
would do a year and come to the Lakers
yeah by the way you make it seem like
he's serving his sentence I'm just
saying
serve a year in Toronto Toronto knew his
time okay Camilla I'll be careful they
got a big Film Festival up there don't
want you it's a beauty I don't work I
want Kauai on a lake I got it the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience